[Music]
I think the favorite lesson that I like
to teach is the Spanish Armada in 1588
sent there by king philip ii of spain
and the defense against the Spanish
Armada led by Queen Elizabeth the first
and what happened to the Spanish Armada
in that situation the reason I like to
teach it is because Spain was the global
superpower in that period Spain had
conquered almost the entire new world
Britain had not England as it was at
that time had not even begun to develop
colonies and the issue of course was
Catholicism and was Catholicism going to
be brought back to England after it had
been kicked out by Elizabeth's father
Henry the eighth
so this was what led Philip believing
that he was an agent of the Almighty to
send this largest of all naval forces
north into the English Channel as a
lunch pad for the reconquest by
Catholicism of England and that's August
of 1588 Elizabeth's strategy was not to
attempt to directly confront that fleet
because she didn't have a fleet it was
capable of doing that she certainly
could not have confronted directly a
Spanish army because she had virtually
no army of her own but she is thinking
in terms of geography she's thinking in
terms of what direction the winds blow
in normally in the English Channel and
she saw that if she just allowed the
Spanish fleet to advance slowly up the
English Channel which it had to do
because it was cumbersome with a few
English ships pursuing it and then
picking them off as they as they pursue
and then as they got up to the border of
what's now Belgium and France where they
were going to disembark
troops realize that taking advantage of
the winds if you just said a few Old
English ships on fire with explosives on
them and send them into the middle of
this huge Spanish fleet that's going to
cause terror and that in itself will be
enough to defeat the Spanish so it's all
happening on one evening with the winds
in the right direction with eight ships
use and the Spanish completely panicked
to the extent of cutting their own
anchor cables so more than a hundred
ships self-destructed in terms of losing
control of the ability to navigate the
only thing they could do then was to
flee but because of the winds they had
to flee around all of England around
Scotland down the Irish coast and by the
time they staggered back into Spain they
were profoundly depleted that's the
turning point that's the moment at which
it can be said the Spanish Empire
reached its high point and then started
descending and it's also the moment at
which we can say the English began to
become very gradually a superpower and
I'm fascinated by the fact that it all
can be reduced to a single night in the
English Channel and to the direction in
which the winds blew so that testifies
to the importance of seizing the moment
it testifies to the importance of not
micromanaging but macro managing in the
sense of delegating authority to the
experts in this case her own sea
captain's trusting them to do the right
thing trusting them to take advantage of
spontaneous moments they didn't have
time to consult Elizabeth about the fire
ships they didn't have time to wonder if
they sacrifice eight ships will she get
mad and cut off their heads they figured
no it's unlikely because she'll be she's
a strategist herself she will understand
what that sacrifice to achieve and of
course that's what happened so it's her
great triumph it's Spain's great failure
and
you can argue it leads to the
development of North America by the
British and to the fact that we are
sitting here speaking English and not
Spanish now
[Music]